♪ ♪ ♪
- Il s'est écoulé six ans
depuis cette nuit de terreur
comme Paris n'en avait jamais
et des centaines de blessés
et des accusés.
Après neuf longs mois de
témoignages e e e plaidoiries,
19 des 20 accusés ont été
reconnus c
les chefs d'accusation par
la Cour sisisises spéciale
de Paris. Salah Abdeslam,
le
des commandos a été condamné
l l la perpétuité incompressib;
une peine qui le prive de
conditionnelle avant 30 ans.Il r
des accusés à s'exprimer lundi
son évolution depuis l'ouverture
du procès. À l'époque, il
s'était empressé de se dire
combattant de l'État islamique.
Puis, il a changé son ton et
ses propos : "Je ne suis pas
un assassin, je ne suis pas
un tueur, avait-il dit lundi,
et si vous me condamnez pour
assassinat, vous commettrez
une injustice."
"Au contraire, dit cette avocate
représentante des victimes,
sa lourde peine est toute
à l'honneur de la cour."TOTOTOT,
avocate des parties civiles
- C'était très important
dans cette gangrène terroriste,
il falEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEs
insister, la cour a eu beaucoup
de courage et je veux saluer
ce courage.
- La cour n'a pas cru l'accuseeé
à se faire exploser. Elle a
plutôt idididéré que son gilet
explosif était défectueux,
remettant sérieusementeseseseses
de Salah Abdeslam sur
son renoncement par humanité,
avait-il
dit cet avocat qui représente
aussi les partis civil
c'est très rare dans notre droit
ananançais. Et ce message
s'adresse à tous les pays
du monde, l
peuvent préparer des attentats,
tolérance zéro.
- Les peines prononcées par
la cour vont de 1 an à 30 ans
de la défense, il s'agit de
pe l l lourdes dont l'étiquette
du terrorisme pose problème.
- Il y a des rac
sont faits, des raccourcis
intellectuels que je trouve
assez dangereux et liberticides,
qu'on l'applique avec plus
de justesse.
- Son client ayant déjà serviunt
la durée du procès, il devrait
être li
Mais, il pourrait malgré
tout faire appel du icicict.
Pour les milliers de partis
civils, le verdict annonce
la fin d'un long processus,
souvent douloureux, parfois
réparateur. Mais c'est aussi
une vie qu'iututut maintenant
inventer.
-
une part de vous-même... et...
c'est difficile uiuiuitter
cet endroit parce que ça été
un endroit où on s'estuiuiuiuiué
- Près de 400 survivants
et membres des famillesntntntnts
à la barre. Ils ont offert
à la cour un récit souvent
glaçant de cette terrible nuit.
à un concert demain soir.IlIlIl.
- Je suis né deux fois.
Le 1vevevembre c'était
ma deuxième naissance, donc
- Vivre, mais sans jamais
oublier les morts.édédédédédédé,
Radio-Canada, Paris.